hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today's
question comes from one of my forms
readers Anthony who wrote in asking to a
business plan and he said is a good
business plan the first thing that you
need to do to start a business as much
of a fan of business plans that i am
anthony and thank you for the question i
think a lot of people go through that
question as well i don't think it's the
first thing that you should do and the
reason being when you're creating your
business plan you should really have a
good sense of your market and what
you're going to do to create your
product and service and sell it and in
the early stages of a business what you
really need to do is start talking to
customers to figure out what kind of
business you should launch and the best
type of business you can launch is start
talking is building around your
customers so you go stop talking to
potential customers find out what the
problems are their pain points and try
to develop a solution that can help them
and we made this mistake one of my
earlier companies we spend the entire
summer dropped in a business client that
we thought was awesome and of course our
customers are going to want this product
and this is no the best thing ever and
we spend so much time researching and
figured we had the best thing but then
when we you know got to actually launch
and it turns out that you know the
customer were going after didn't really
care give us a time of day now luckily
we had you know enough still in our
product to make it successful we would
find other customers but we spent all
this time creating this business plan
that we thought was amazing and then
when we went to actually tested in the
market we found out that it didn't hold
any water so the best thing you do at
the beginning you're first starting your
business or you're thinking about
certain to business is go start talking
to customers and they'll tell you what
they need what they like how you can
help them and from there you'll get the
information you need to be able to
create your business plan the danger
doing it the other way is your business
plan will be you know useless and
extinct you know the day you actually
start going on marketing the product as
you launch your business your business
plan is going to change you're going to
get new opportunities customers will
come with the new problems your
marketing strategy will change your
expenses might change
little bit so your business plan will
constantly have to change a little bit
but it's best if you can to have a good
concept from the beginning built around
what you know will sell and what
customers want so my number one thing if
you're starting the business is just go
start talking to customers find out the
problems build the solution around their
needs and then once you've got a sense
of what their challenges are and you
will to get a couple orders ideally
coming in you can create your business
plan on how you're going to create this
no company out of this you know idea and
be able to grow and expand to other
companies build a team build your
facilities if you need to continue to
grow the business so hopefully that
helps Anthony those are you watching if
you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up I always love seeing those
come in and if you have a thought for
Anthony or you have a question I'd love
the hero deform leave a comment
underneath the video so thank you and
you'll see you on the next episode
you